okay
so
as a white girl that's a six
and a black girl that's a six yeah
it's not the same six
elaborate
you've done it
right this is not for me to ask this is
for like the masters in it where whereas
watching maybe they can you know add
their comment in him but
do you feel like a white girl that's a
six and a black girl that's a six is the
same six
and also do you feel that a white
goddess of 10 is the same as a black
girl that's a 10.
what do you mean though
so what what what's the difference to
you
no comment
no you can't start
so i'm guessing one of which is more
your type so once you're better yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so it's like you so
whichever one is more your time so like
you're going to write so
so are you saying like
so you're saying like cause i know
you're being shy
a black like is it like a black girl
that's a six who's better looking than a
white girl that's a six is that what
you're saying are you saying the other
way i'm not no i'm saying like
because this question here sounds like
you know when someone goes oh what's
heavier like a kilogram of fever of a
kilogram of bricks
that's about to get but like i feel like
there's an obvious answer but it's not
obvious
no what did what what are you saying
what are you saying i think it's what
you i'm i'm out of the loop
unless i got it
what i asked people to rate me the other
day or one to ten yeah yeah i'm i'm kind
of harsh on people but yeah
what did you say what did you say i want
to know the gas gone in
it's all right
i'm gonna i'm an actor i get judged all
the time it's okay um i said i'd give
you
oh i said i give you a sex right yeah
yeah yeah that's right wait wait but
there's more um but i said it depends on
or because okay here's my i didn't say
the other thing no no
if you're the girl's type
because like i do the kevin samuels
skill and this is how i rate it like
eight to ten is like you could make
money off of just your face like you
could model five six is pretty cute okay
i'm a solid seven so i i said like if i
had to pick one i'd i'd say six for you
but if you're a girl's type then you
would move up yeah because like i think
you can go up or down a point based on
like if you're someone's height i would
like for example like there's certain
guys that have like a thing for like
tall gingers like it's very it's very
niche right i don't know someone i went
to drama school with no i trained just
like it's a yeah like when they find me
they fall in love because there's just
not many of us
but like that's what i'm saying like in
that point like i get a point because
i'm like they're tight yeah so
um so i'm i think are you saying the
same thing with like white and black
exactly
yeah yeah so wait so what was your sorry
you you repeat that again
[Music]
listen to black white gold that's a six
on the black girl for six it's not the
same type of six mm-hmm but
a white girl that's a ten and the black
girl is a ten
feels like two different tens
so which one which one's more your type
careful emily's
shot you know
listen
listen i feel like it's black girls
because he doesn't want to say it
because we're here
correct on me now so it is so fun to see
you squirm like can i just you can you
can say it's okay yeah
i just got called out at six on one okay
don't worry about it
it's okay
oh my god i feel like okay
i've i was thinking about my results i
give myself a five so it's not like that
like i'd give you more than that to be
honest
thank you
i know people just look at me as like
sad
okay i go off all like facial symmetry
so that's what i mean like eight to ten
means your face is so symmetrical on
your face alone you can model like
people you've probably had modeling
agents approach you in your life
six is cute
five is like like average and like so i
would say like five maybe six that's
what i would give myself
and like eight to ten like because i've
never had people ask me to model but my
scale sounds harsher than it really is
because everyone else rates themselves
as a seven but i don't give anyone
sevens because you have to pick you're
either on the more average side or on
you're on the model side
i think that's fair the conversation
that i've had is like
are you a a local
team or a worldwide
celebrity skill yeah yeah it's like you
can say oh
did this go wherever um hannah whatever
she's a she's a servant cool like we
understand that she's
reasonably good looking
but
around the world if you take her like
out of what we know take it somewhere
else she probably wouldn't like three or
four
right well there's like it's like
hollywood scale versus like a normal
scale yeah but i think like when i do it
i kind of make it like the hollywood
scale like normal you know what i mean
like there aren't many eights to tens in
general
i'll tell you and i would i would also i
would i would also say that hollywood is
what a lot of these people don't even
look like how we think they look because
instagram it's such a very like and also
filters photoshop i think it's such a
real thing
i think that uh
a lot of the time we see these people
completely airbrushed when you see
people in film too like i'd like to
point out as someone who works in film
they have the best lighting on them they
have they do not have
nice daylight
nobody even
even this is nicer lighting than bright
sunlight if you were to stand out
tonight although yeah i would like to
point out i definitely look like casper
the ghost like
like different skin tones and this is
another thing in film side note but like
trying to balance if you've got a scene
between someone who's very white and
someone who's much darker skinned it's
diff because you've got to like them
different
but oh hey what was that series that had
um
i swear it was produced
by oprah or something and it was
exclusively black cast and i've never
seen black people lit so well in it it
was a tv series and it was so good queen
something or other
i can't remember what it was now
i can't remember man but it was so good
it was a really really good series too
but if you want it yeah man that was so
well lit anyway um now what were we
saying oh who's doing ik i think my 10
out of 10 i was thinking about well you
guys were talking there's a female model
she's called
a boa
and i think she is the most good looking
person i've ever seen and she's so good
latino no she's mixed she's mixed her
mum is ginger and her dad is black
actually question how many points does a
good ass add to a girl
like honestly like three points three
points yeah
what do you what do you guys think a
good ass what does that add to a girl
how many points two
two oh get us to a guy that's a lot it
does a lot yeah at least at least four
that's why margot robbie's no
at least four years
because a good ass kid i don't know what
you look but more of a physical person
than a face person
okay here's okay here's a question
here's a question to you guys would you
take
a great body and average face or a great
face but an average body a great body
and average face 100
great
body great body yeah great body same
really and i think that's what i think
you're the other way around which is why
you really rate margaret robbie and we
don't um oh yeah yeah that is because
i'm because when i rate people i'm going
off your facial like symmetry like
that's what i mean i think so someone
someone thinks they're like
you do have
like someone's physical
their physicality is going to play into
you can't just go from their face did
you not see margot robbie's
wall street she has a great body yeah
yeah
but but
i'm really i don't i'm not inter i don't
really like i'm not attracted to margot
robbie i'm not into her you're so nuts
but she's gorgeous
i see why people i see why people i
don't know
no no no no
she's all real do you guys oh i have a
question i have a question for you do
you guys care a question all right see i
keep forgetting your bi so you can
answer this too do you guys care if a
girl's fake at all like she has a great
ass but it's fake great lips but they're
fake and like how much fake is too fake
it's like just yes or no yes
what's the question
do you care if a girl's like fake at all
like that's fake
not to write her off
don't hit this yes yes no i care
okay yes or no i would never write
someone off
i in general
prefer people who come as they are yeah
guy anger yeah
i'll they mess around with but not
serious that's not i wouldn't want to
not fake no yeah i'd have the same
answers as well so yeah yeah so would
you take a less attractive girl then
that's like more natural yeah
100 yeah no even regardless of wife and
up or no i would rather be with someone
who
had these imperfe
whatever as well i would like to say
that a lot of the things that people try
and fix with plastic surgery and
especially when it comes to women's
plastic surgery they are trends like the
fat ass things there was nothing until
like nicki minaj lips look so bad i'm
sorry i'm gonna say it all these girls
look like ducks like with the fake
injection i can't i can't look at it and
again this is another thing of in photos
especially when it's well lit mate you
can make a lot of things look good that
in real life you actually can't like i
would say i would rather have someone
and accept them floors and all and have
someone who especially if it was like
not tastefully done i guess that's
another thing but i think for the most
part like i'd rather have someone who
goes yeah you know what i'm not perfect
love me as i am i'd rather have that i
do you think that
so when you like rape people okay
so you know the whole like chad tyrone
yeah
a chaz tyrones are they like sixes and
above eights and above what do you
what's
the chad eight to ten yeah so do you
think someone who's not a chad
or tyrone
who clarified chad and tyrone
tell me eight to ten
eight to ten yeah but then it's hard
it's hard to rate men because like men
it's like women it's more
straightforward like what's your weight
what's your fault like what's your face
that's pretty much it
give or take you know maybe she's a
natural like hourglass or whatever but
men it's harder because
you could have a guy that's a chad but
he's broke
and so where does that make him fall is
he a real chat or a fake but like
looks wise i just go off of your height
and your face shoal symmetry so because
someone who's not a chat of tyrone
no i guess he could yeah that's true
okay